hi everyone I'm Richard and this is the
classic MSI version of the GTX 970 a
frankly historic piece of PC Hardware
when it came out it blew away amd's
entire high-end range it duked it out
with nvidia's own GTX 780 Ti and yeah
overclock it and you've got GTX 980
performance or something very close to
it all for just
$330 so the question is this can the GT
X 1070 repeat the trick well the answer
is yes and also kind of no too what we
have here is the founders edition of the
card essentially nvidia's reference
model physically it looks pretty much
like the GTX 1080 with the same port
configuration the same backing plate and
the same 8 Pin power input internally
the cooler has been downgraded attach
though the 1080s vapor chamber isn't
here but it's still very quiet and
reasonably cool too and at the Silicon
level it's essentially a cutdown version
of the higher-end model and the cutbacks
are quite a lot more substantial than
the ones we saw in the 970 so for
example we lose 25% of the overall
Shader count memory bandwidth drops by
20% and clocks are tweaked a touch lower
too so the question is is the 1070 worth
it well let's take a look at the
generational leap that Nvidia has
actually delivered here so this is the
division running maxed out at 1080p
resolution and we're going to kick off
with the GTX 770 here which is
essentially the GTX 680 with Boost clock
tweaks and faster memory frame rate goes
as low as 18 FPS but the average isn't
really so bad at 30 now let's bring in
the 970 and you can see just how much of
an improvement we got there it's 66%
faster and of course it has twice the
amount of vram too so just how much
faster is today's GTX 1070 well it's 56%
faster than the 970 in this title and
158% faster than the old GTX 770 and
that's not bad in fact Nvidia is
claiming that this card offers up
performance on par with Titan X so yeah
actually the 1070 is mostly faster in
the tests we carried out in fact let's
add the Titan x to the division
comparison we have here so yeah you can
see that it's about I don't know 6%
faster overall the GTX 1080 was really
exciting because because it pushed back
new barriers in terms of performance and
better still it managed to do that
across the whole gamut of different
resolutions but GTX 1070 doesn't have
quite the same wow factor it's a value
play and it's a damn good one offering
frankly stupid levels of performance at
an attractive price point but there is
that price hike to
$380 and another 80 on top if you go for
the founders Edition and remember the
970s party trick of overclocking to 980
performance levels well you're not going
to going to get that here GTX 1080 well
it's an absolute monster and Nvidia has
worked hard to protect the value of that
price premium so here's a look at how
the 1070 overclocks based on some 1440p
benchmarks we put together now we're
using offset overclocking here so there
is the argument that we're perhaps not
getting the most out of the new features
with GPU boost 3.0 however what's clear
from our testing is that even if you
really push that core clock this GP U
isn't really going to push Beyond 2 GHz
whether it's the thermals or much more
likely the power limit you can keep on
upping that core clock offset but the
actual GPU itself will still settle
around the 2 GHz level the gddr5 RAM on
the other hand well you already get 8
GHz effective here I push this up easily
to 9.4 which is not bad at all in fact
it's within Striking Distance of g5x on
the GTX 1080 which is quite remarkable
the end result well we're looking at
about 14% % of additional performance
here with plus 140 MHz to the core clock
and plus 700 to the ram now that core
increase in particular might seem a
little bit low especially compared to
the Maxwell era OC's we saw on reference
cards but as I said you can push that
core higher but certainly in the case of
this review card the actual results
won't exceed that 2 GHz limit now
perhaps we'll see something a little
different a little better perhaps from
partner cards so let's wrap this up then
will the GTX 1070 radically shape up the
GPU Market in the way its predecessor
did well perhaps not it's a touch more
expensive and its overclocking prow
isn't quite so impactful as its
predecessor but the bottom line is that
Nvidia promised Titan X level
performance for this particular product
and in that respect it's not only
delivered in many ways it has overd
delivered bottom line is it's the faster
card overall now just like the titanex I
think your struggle to run the latest
titles effectively at 4K with
but for every other single screen
application this GPU offers a phenomenal
amount of performance it may well be the
case that it has been cut down
significantly from the GTX 1080 but
unlike its predecessor there's no funny
business with the vram here and in fact
with 8 gigs very very fast vram on tap
you're more effectively futureproof than
the Alternatives that are available on
the market right now so that's GTX 1070
then we have a massive and I mean
massive bunch of Gaming benchmarks
Elsewhere on the channel and they're all
Linked In the video description below
but in the meantime that's all I've got
for you do like and subscribe to support
the work we do but for now thanks for
watching